[Musique]
les chansons de barbe drue valent leur
pesant d'or et a eu seuls les droits de
tout le catalogue aurait été cédé pour
près de 300 millions de dollars
américains
[Musique]
brent à 79 ans je crois que c'est dit je
venais personne de confiance pour gérer
mon catalogue
il voulait pas que sa famille gère s'ils
avaient à partir y avait nos critiques
donc je trouve ton move intelligent qui
fait
ag
les temps changent en effet et il ne se
vend plus autant de disques que dans le
bon vieux temps
mais les droits d'édition sont encore là
c'est ce qui explique pourquoi le groupe
innovation de musique allie la main sur
les 600 chansons de dilemme
[Applaudissements]
aide à la décision du skal font l'objet
de beaucoup de surenchères cézanne ici
parce que tous s'en vont vers les droits
il ya plus beaucoup de ventes physiques
donc si l'utilisation de musique une
utilisation dans des films ecce terra
sol y en a encore pour plusieurs années
depuis près de 60 ans barbe darden a
composé de nombreux chefs-d'oeuvre qu'on
pense à la colonne stoneking on heaven's
door
mais trois reprises
[Musique]
on peut pas créer un nouveau bac
d'aulnay tels que l'industrie est fait
aujourd'hui c'est impossible impossible
on ne peut créer que dtn reçoivent des
drake decani ouest enfin db entier et
sert à ça c'est faisable mais des
artistes d'une telle profondeur
chansonnière c'est absolument pas les
droits d'édition n'appartiennent pas
toujours aux artistes qui ont composé
les chansons qu'on pense à paul
mccartney qui à une certaine époque
n'avait plus les droits des chansons des
beatles mais bob dylan avait toujours
conservé ses droits d'édition une pose
un geste exceptionnel mais évidemment
c'est payant mort si je crois dans ce
sens en temps jusqu'à son extrême on
entendra encore de bob bell
[Musique]
ici louis fait dépouiller mais
radio-canada mots rien
[Musique]